with smoking some [ __ ] heroin tonight
baby you're making noises over like a
little piglet it's going up with you oh
[Music]
[ __ ]
the achievers infinite yellow
[Music]
rotten [ __ ] uncle Joey here
tonight preacher chin it with you
[ __ ] I'm here with my trusted
[ __ ] goombah Lisa at who's trying to
eat some [ __ ] brothers wait till you
see this [ __ ] picture you people dad
this there's more or less he wanna
brownies time we got this cheap but not
too cheap at you brownies we got the
[ __ ] Anarchy brownie and Swiss blue
cheapest you'll be all right bro we come
at you for more [ __ ] directions you
understand me
it's Monday night [ __ ] [ __ ] the
Emmys [ __ ] all this [ __ ] that's going on
it's about us and that's it it's just
about us to let two little [ __ ]
chubby dudes getting high and talking
[ __ ] we got a great guest tonight we got
everything lined up I'm sorry I couldn't
meet you [ __ ] savages of Black
Sabbath but [ __ ] work comes first and
I got the album right here nobody loses
any sleep you understand me at the end
of the day nobody loses sleep life
[ __ ] goes on I saw him what
30-something [ __ ] years ago with Van
Halen I'm an old man I saw him with deal
I'm good I don't need to bother nobody
I'll need to do nothing cuz you got a
park and walk up the [ __ ] Hill then
bump into more [ __ ] creepy people you
know what I'll stay with my little
brother tonight at least I ask and we'll
do a little podcast a little take it
right there that's where he goes time
for [ __ ]
begins nobody's get six while the
chocolate this is the funds of mom gets
after sickness he goes there he goes is
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
though training since [ __ ] Friday
we're back [ __ ] you understand me
[Music]
there's what happens when you don't
train since [ __ ] last Wednesday but
we're back his face is red as eyeball on
the
[Music]
oh whoa whoa this heroin is on fire
tonight listen to this [ __ ] I got a mule
on the way to New York already look at
look look at this I got an ounce for
this headed to New York look at this ha
ha life is killing you look at this
[ __ ]
could you imagine finger-banging your
[ __ ] girl for this thing look at
these [ __ ] loves of debt oh yeah
Rosie is enroute right now that's how I
make it happen [ __ ] oh we got some
beautiful weed here tonight beautiful
we got least-favorite remove [ __ ]
cookies last time look at this look at
this monstrosity oh [ __ ] and you thought
it was gonna be a ho-hum night at your
residence I've told you once I've told
you a thousand times
go to Grandma steel to valiums get a
[ __ ] whiskey and smoke some reefer
with uncle Joey tonight cause it's going
down there's gonna be a rough week bombs
in New Jersey terrorists in Connecticut
envelopes the emmys what the [ __ ]
Lee you ready you stop sway
but the one when you do one that was a
training that was that's laughing you
know Gong it for a few days
that hello why they [ __ ] around
people you think I go to a Wheatstone
get this [ __ ] on the low shelf [ __ ] no
it's top shelf [ __ ]
just like that nobody gets their
feelings hurt nobody loses a tooth
nobody does not bond hit for Pocket
[ __ ] it's just a way of life here in
the Churchill what's happening now and
then you ain't down with it I get it
I'm not down with [ __ ] pills and [ __ ]
like that you know
uber and [ __ ] so I understand your
situations what's up that Johnny you but
Catalina Island beautiful [ __ ] clouds
were blowing here from out in the church
humor limbus Nimbus I'm blowin
all-weather [ __ ] clouds up here had a
[ __ ] bloody nose for an hour today
like Advil after jujitsu and then this
theme it opens up this cat scratching a
[ __ ] towel full of blood to their I'm
surprising him passer I'm surprising him
fast
that hides the universal secret our
Volta this is the Shh the trip there's a
kick and you imagine this [ __ ] listen
for this [ __ ] stuff
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
will it acid dim the lights with the
earphones on prayer I've lived a
thousand times I found out what it means
to be bad down a nano nano is as good as
it gets [ __ ]
[Music]
ready buddy there's a tip top of coupons
[Music]
Vidia one is ready do a couple dr.
polices and your stomach that's it
[ __ ] get your diaphragm working for
the bong you got me wanna get you wanna
be a good bong hitter
you gotta get the diaphragm working like
that they mark the [ __ ] bullies said
[Music]
nice and slow you know rush get that
diaphragm working you're the boss you're
the boss there you go there you go boop
boop be doop sighs nothing
[Music]
understand me fungus every day you can
next time we're taking the portable bomb
to Austin Texas good you can't get out
of palm shake [ __ ] but he did do
the whole [ __ ] bump I gotta hand it
to when we goes deep he goes deep is
going to be tight
[Applause]
[ __ ]
[Music]
except that cold by the exact second
[Music]
we don't know it's just a regular Monday
night I don't know what's going on in
football who gives a [ __ ] I didn't bet
the game who's playing Chicago how's
that game what Adam see little [ __ ]
torture chamber
[Music]
I'm trying to get through are you
kidding me what what you think I would
show up for a [ __ ] water gun
[Music]
yeah we want summe I'm just trying to
pull up the old [ __ ] mind
look at this for the [ __ ] Brimble
going deep on this well it's maybe it's
ours [ __ ] I can stone the start doing
new chucks in this the [ __ ] you think
you're dealing with some nominee lunch
even should we go and beat time when I
sweat that call
it's hot here
[Music]
we don't [ __ ] around over five years ago
we was the law look at him that was
[ __ ] gone Austin he's got [ __ ]
fans and awesome people showed up to
kissing his drinking [ __ ]
he's a big shot how meny
you see but you know 5/7 KOCO 5 you're
the same put that thing on my sax and I
froze electrons the Fed machine so
Madison my back feels a lot better but
do it again when I get home
[Music]
somewhere did that [ __ ] garbage a
couple weeks ago
about it tonight the smoke of war Rufus
[ __ ] you guys was going on your world
your life you know I love the concept
what are you guys I have nothing not
even leave a shot
[Music]
his [ __ ] sheepish she went over there
they pass police I do a half we get
[ __ ] colors Football Hall of Fame I
just do about the church
besides that that's it that's not
I've missed you guys I show you this
we'll look like a brief of your the
neighborhood brother
[Music]
marijuana from perennial and as always
don't use a [ __ ] kill you you follow
[Music]
that loud
[Music]
now we're back and [ __ ] you know family
from that day we were a little lost but
no worries everything's good you're
gonna have a good week you wrote your
[ __ ] goals you think your push-ups
and beside that that's it you got
everything covered
plus you got something nobody else got
you got yong-chol Joey it can't be bad
right
no I'm not looking for London but
something goes down you uncle Joey you
hit me up Joey this guy stabbed me
should i perish it off the building and
[ __ ] cut his neck off and we'll put
it together
Josh Adam - that's my little brother -
[ __ ] Baltimore ago - oh my is Lee Harvey
Oswald there's no difference man I got
the house you liked him the first time
but I need a little peace and I get to
[ __ ] nausea of that nausea of death
one time a fiend gave me one only now
cancel my set it was harmed during that
and then I got him for the Mohs surgery
yeah a couple weeks ago a little 25
milligrams I call my bunny goes my you
gotta go deep cook you gotta eat 7500
relative when I there they big I they
slaughtered think these are the 25 s I
had one tiny tiny not tiny later blue
white and then the 350s look like a
vitamin the three fifties by a percocet
okay
the 25 milligrams that's you make money
on that before really 25 milligrams yeah
I can't goes it's like 20 30 dollars a
pill what got it do not talk did you
[ __ ] you up not what I want not what I
was looking for me yeah go ahead
not what I was looking for you know hey
you got a good bill I'll [ __ ] eat it
weed it together but if they gonna do
not tell me I'd only do it again if it's
just gonna [ __ ] me up I'm open to
anything
you don't mean you don't put Joey I'm a
[ __ ] soldier at death well I have to
Serge you got the oxycottons I was
excited I took I was gonna see the devil
what the [ __ ] is everybody talking about
nothing I don't throw them away and in
the [ __ ] 350 my friend gave me
they're not bad then I'll [ __ ] you up
but they neutralize your real quick
sometimes a toy it is to be neutralized
I'm talking about like Lisa I look at
means neutralized right yeah let's not
need to do right now we got to still got
brownies you get your Chi but you look a
little black sperm frozen for you there
Jesus Christ you'd never be a Boston red
Sun by the door by the door turn around
it's just Christ Almighty's even a
little older let's do some blue so let's
do so lilies like I can't Joey I can't I
can't do it doesn't matter that that's a
good thing that you know what you do
yeah you don't think a thing of my lungs
you always got one extra you got one
that's it that's all you need Louise
along when I was a kid Louie the lung he
could run from here the side acid with
no [ __ ] problems he had one alone
[ __ ] does he lost it he got shot or
something I don't [ __ ] I'll ask
questions little long was a good dude he
wasn't from not Bergen Louie the lung
chitchat a little bit [ __ ] this
[ __ ]
leave the [ __ ] Man of Steel little
[ __ ]
tougher than dead [ __ ] what's the
war when the Jews held off the [ __ ]
Russians for 2,000 days this guy is good
guys we'll be back in ten minutes
whistle to finish off [ __ ] the Sabbat
side I hope you enjoyed yourself
I hope you know listen you guys all I
got I love when you tune in we spoke a
couple bong hits and everybody's happy
to go home and that's it that's what
uncle Joey does we come home we go come
abundance you want to give me a [ __ ]
hamburger I'll take it if not I'm happy
get him say ten minutes [ __ ]
Churchill has happened now YouTube
that's right cuts in slash please that
Joey these stay black